الانتماء لهذه الجنديديه تحيه لكل من
اصابه جرح او اصابه ضرر او اصابه اي مخبصه
في سبيل الدفاع عن السودان وفي سبيل
ارتداء هذا الشعار شعار العسكريه
نحن كلنا
كاس عساكرناه
وحنظل نعمل فيها
اخر لحظه من عمرنا
عن سلاحنا ولا حاجه
ولا احد يتخلى عن كله قيمه تعلمناها
وورثناها من هذا الجيش الجيش العظيمه
الجيش السوداني
معانا هنا
عن شعب السودان وحمايه عن ارض السودان
نحن طبعا كلنا متابعين
ما حل ببلدنا وكلنا متابعين
محله من تغيير في القوات المسلحه القوات
المسلحه
غيرت كثير من الماضي
وتحمي هذا البلد وتحمي مواطن هذا البلد
يحيى طبعا في الجيش عندنا صحيح جزء من
المشاكل الشعب السوداني نحنا بنعيشه
وبنعانيها
لكن احنا ناكد ليكم انه نحن لن نلقوا
اي طريقه
لانه نوفر لجنودنا ونوفر لافرادنا اذا كان
في الخدمه
من النوم
يكونوا قادرين انه يحمل السلاح واداره عن
السودان عشان كذا اهتمام بدنا نحنا في
القياده واخوانكم ده كلهم
مبكرا لانه احنا اهتم بالجندي ده
مهتم بمعيشته مهتم بعلاجه
[موسيقى]
وقفه حقيقيه بتاعت اخوان واقفه حقيقيه وهم
بيستحقوها
جرحه الشهداء
نحنا في هذه الايام برضه بنعيش ظروف
استثنائيه ظروف سياسيه
معلومه للجميع
لكن احنا من هذا الموقف لانكد للشعب
السوداني انه هذه القوات المسلحه هي من
الشعب السوداني وهذه القوات المسلحه هي
حمايه للشعب السوداني
وهذه القوات المسلحه
السوداني
حق الشعب السوداني عشان كده احنا ما حنضيف
ولا حنتاخر السوداني
[موسيقى]
نحن قاعدين نبكي ان القوات المسلحه الفتره
الماضي
تتعرض للهجوم هجوم جديد جدا
لن تناله من هذه القوات المسلحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من هذه القوات ونحن قاعدين وانتم قاعدين
من السودان نحنا قاعدين وانتم قاعدين
طالما احنا عندنا
قضيه رئيسيه قضيتنا الله والوطن شعار ثاني
نحن
الجيش انه الجيش موالي للجهه معين ولا
الحج معين الجيش زمان
نحنا بنحذر الناس الدائرين الدار ولا
الجيش
من القوات المسلحه
[تصفيق]
القوات المسلحه
الان صحيح الناس سامعين بانه في مفاوضات
في كلام صحيح نحن في بعض الشباب من القدس
الوطنيه
ومعها نسمع كلامه
حتى اذا كان في اي مجموعه جاء نحن شايفين
الانشقاق السياسيه والاحزاب كل دول عنده
ورقه ولا عنده وثيقه دارنا يتبعوه فيها
ان شاء الله عليه ورقه بيضاء ما في اي
كتابه
تروح وهو الجامد في المباراه
للحوار
يتكلم فيها
كلام نحن بنقوله والنموذج
انا مستعدين نموت عشان ندافع عن الجيش
لانه الجيش ده هو اللي بدافع عن السودان
هسه الناس بيقولوا لابس انا بقيت لابس
ومعمره هذه
قاعد ادورها
[تصفيق]
ما في كلام ما في لعب
نحن جيشنا ده نحميه بيروحنا ومستعدين في
اي لحظه وفي اي وقت في اي لحظه وفي اي وقت
مدافع عنه لانه الدفاع عنه دفاع عن
السودان
[موسيقى]
الدفاع عن هذا الجيش دفاع عن السودان نحن
كلامنا ده موجه لكل القوى السياسيه
[موسيقى]
ينحاز لاي فئه ولا هيجيب في 7 اي فئه
الجيش واقف مع السودان واقف مع وحده
السودان واقف معه حق السودان لانه
سودانيين يعيشوا عيشه كريمه يحيى حياه
كريمه
نحن
في تفاهمات لكن تفاهمات بالنسبه لنا احنا
تفاهمات في حاجات خطوط حمر بالنسبه لنا
اول هذه القوات المسلحه والقوات النظاميه
كلها خط احمر غير مسموح بانه حد يعب
الزاويه يلعب بها
في 2019
اذا كانت مسيره الحريه والتغيير
معاهم عشان نكمل الفتره الانتقاليه لكن من
الفتره انت غاليه عشان تجيني انتخابات غير
الناس 2019 ايضا وظيفتهم قوه سياسيه اخرى
هذا الكلام اللي احنا قاعد نتكلم عنه
نقوله الداري يخش معنا في المساله
السودان
ما بتستحمل قالوا الناس يتجاوزكم فيها وكل
دول ماسك ورقه وكل مبادره
لان اذبح الوطن نذبح مصلحه الوطن
نحن بنحييكم وبنعرفكس عمي والله القوات
المسلحه دي لا مؤتمر وطني لا حركه اسلاميه
لا حزب شيوعي لاي زول ما عنده فيها كلام
ولا عنده فيها شيء ولا تتبعون ولا تحرر
ولا حتى زكي لها زول عشان نحكم الكلام ده
ما نقوله لانه الناس يقولوا الجيش يقول
جيزان الجيش بدي اعمل المؤتمر وطني لانه
ده كلام كذب ده كذب ده قليل في ناس
احنا عارفين وبنقول برده الوطني 2019
عادي ثوره نحن نريد ان تكون ثوره حقيقيه
ثوره تلبي طموحاته وتلبي احلامه
الشباب السوداني فيها معينه تعيد له
المواسي ولا المظالم كان ب 20 نقول لهم
نحن الاشاعات والكلام اللي تسمعوه ولا
الجيش
زي الجيش السوداني ما حك اي زون نحن كفاده
واجبنا انه نحافظ عليهم نحافظ عليه
تماسكو نحافظ عليهم موحد ضامن لهذه الوحده
السودانيه ضمن لهذا الشعب السوداني لانه
هو من الشعب السوداني نحنا دخلنا الجيش
السوري
من 30 72
اشتغلنا في فصائل ما كنا
[موسيقى]
بنعرفهم
دول
كثير
ما بنعرف
[موسيقى]
الناس ما يسمعوا كلام انه في وثيقه
دستوريه فيها تفكيك جيش الكلام ده كذب
ونحن ننضم نبصم والله نمضي لينا في حاجه
بفكر الجيش ولا على نفسه
حريصين زي ما انتم حريصين على وحده
السودان حريصين على الامن السودان
[موسيقى]
الوطنيه الحادبه على حمايه السودان
الفتره الانتقاليه تكمل بتراضي بين معظم
السودانيين كلهم
مصلحه البلد كله
ما عنده نقط قطع الشك بعدها اتفقنا عليهم
المؤتمر الوطني
الجيش في ناس يتكلموا عن الجيش انه الجيش
حمل جيش عمله الجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
ابن يحيكم
معكم لانكم انتم واقفين عشان السودان
يكونوا قاعدين بدون حكومه ثلاثه سنين كل
شيء ماشي الحكومه
التوافق